[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in dan orlowski espn
football analyst you can see him on nfl
live monday through friday at 4 eastern
with laura rutledge mina kimes marcus
spears ryan clark adam schefter
uh the first question it's not football
related what makes steph curry so great
dan
i i i don't know i've i've talked about
it a lot how great he is
he's good at everything thank you for
playing along is that is there a player
that you've run out of ways to describe
how great they are
uh tom is up there yeah i mean
you know tom is certainly up there
because he's done it for so long at such
a high high level um
i thought rivas was there years ago um
revis was a guy that got up there but i
would say tom you know aaron
definitely aaron is still there you know
and it's he's great because of the same
stuff he's been great for for a decade
but you had mahomes who felt like he was
on the cusp of that but now all of a
sudden we kind of you know started
chopping away at his pedestal here where
where's mahomes now in uh on the list of
quarterbacks in the nfl this season
yeah i mean if we're just talking about
this season you know patrick's probably
guys that have played better than
patrick um
thomas played better
um
lamar's played better deck um
dak has played better
matthew stafford's played better
josh allen's played better so i mean
patrick's probably somewhere around the
six or seven range as far as just
performance this year i would still if i
had
the you know the the two three four five
pick in next year's nfl drafted patrick
was a guy that i could pick i'd trade
all four of those picks for the number
one spot to go get him i think he's been
a lot better the past two or three weeks
stan a lot better um mechanically he's
been so much better you could tell
that's been an emphasis
um you know i think that this past
weekend you know was a great performance
when it came to the end result
production you could see he was very
purposeful you know i kind of said that
this week he threw the ball 50 times
against the raiders 44 times he got the
ball out in one hitch or less that's
intent to be completion driven he will
not have that experience against the
cowboys though the cowboys are not going
to give him completions like that this
week so he's been better um and he's
still the most talented guy at the
position
we see golfers get in bad habits how do
quarterbacks get into bad habits even
the great ones
yeah you have success within those bad
habits you know the kind of the way i
phrased it was
bad process good results
you know he was having good results and
this is for a stretch a period of time
and it's a fine line dan because you
don't want to take that away from him
that's his super powers he's able to
play
so well and be so accurate and make the
correct throw at the correct time when
everything isn't
kind of perfect or right but when you
have a stretch of period a period of
time where you have
a good result but a bad process that's
how you get into bad habits and you know
bad habits aren't something that
happened overnight they happen over a
long period of time and it and that's
why i say like there's that saying in
the nfl winning cures everything that's
a myth winning covers everything and
it's really difficult to go in as a
coach and go hey patrick we really gotta
make sure that we're focused every
single day on our fundamentals when he
goes hey man i just threw for 380 and
four touchdowns you know like what what
you know so you you've got to be so
obsessive and nitpicky in a way and
focusing on the things that could i
remember then aaron rodgers went through
this you know aaron rodgers went through
stuff where because these guys are so
physically gifted
so physically gifted and they can do so
much without having to be drew brees or
without having to be tom or without
having to be even a guy like right now
like kirk cousins those guys have to be
correct all the time technically and
mechanically aaron went through this
years ago when he he started his play
started to dip and it was like what you
know the some of the mechanics when the
talent starts to just drop a little bit
you've got to kind of counter that with
with those mechanics and and
technical stuff and you know it seems
like patrick like i said of the past
couple weeks is is started to show some
better stuff in regards to that better
understanding of the chiefs right now or
the cowboys right now
oh the cowboys the cowboys completely i
think the cowboys the the broncos game
was that blip in the radar i i said this
i don't know if there's a team
in the nfc and i think there's a team in
the afc maybe buffalo i don't think
there's a team in the nfc
offensively that one has absolutely
physically dominated people the way the
cowboys offense has in multiple games
this year i don't think there's a team
in the nfc that can line up and go we
will beat you on offense however you
want us to however you want us to both
they can and they will they got the
people to do it and they've got the
coaching to do it you want us to throw
50 times we'll throw at 50. you want us
to run at 50 we'll run at 50. i don't
think there's a team in the nfc that has
done that and then i don't think there's
a defense in the nfc that has suffocated
offenses more than the dallas cowboys
defense has this year and so i think
that's we got a really good
understanding of who dallas is i know
kansas city has played better uh
in the past couple weeks i just doing my
job defensively they've been better off
the past two weeks they played jordan
love and they played the raiders without
henry ruggs the raiders are wildly
different offense without henry rhodes
um and i think offensively
like like i said the raiders scheme-wise
defense is we are going to give you
these completion i mean they had 264
yards after the catch on offense kansas
city the other night so i have said it's
nice to see but i got to see it against
dallas
former nfl quarterback now espn football
analyst dan olofsky joining us uh just a
bad night for the rams or is there a
bigger picture here
i think there's a little bit of a bigger
picture definitely a bad night i think
offensively they were exposed in one
very specific area that's the
interior of their offensive line you
know i've talked to all season how
they've gone to this empty mindset empty
package five guys in protection five
guys out as pass catchers and they've
had a ton of success with it but then
they've played two really good defensive
lines in
tennessee two weeks ago and then san
francisco and the interior their
offensive line has gotten beat up
and i think sean mcvay needs to go back
to a little bit of what got him here now
what i mean by that is put the
quarterback under center and use more
play action pass a lot of times
people
myself included will say you got to do
more of that because it's to help the
quarterback hey let's help our
quarterback it's it's stuff that
quarterbacks see well they don't have to
know the coverage they can just go
through progressions one two to three
you know you can create chunks with it i
think they need to do it to protect with
what right now is their greatest
weakness on offense and that's the right
guard the center and the left guard
those three guys in the middle and when
you do that one defensive lineman don't
know it's going to be a pass you know
when you get into that empty set
defensive lineman don't you've made them
play one dimensional it's a past voice
you know when we can go be pass rushers
when you put them under center and use
some run play action they don't know
it's a pass they can work in unison a
lot more in the play action game you're
moving the launch point for the
quarterback sometimes he's behind the
center sometimes behind the guard
sometimes behind the tackle which
tackles it going to be sometimes he's
outside the pocket so those guys
defensive line wise got to move and so
it helps the offensive line so i really
think this is a
a moment
similar to tampa last year hey i
remember pounding the tables like tampa
you gotta you gotta go more play action
for tom you gotta keep them protected
you gotta use motion more well they did
after they're by and it helps i think
it's similar to that and then i just
touch on the defense dan like
the they are
philosophically what's going on in the
nfl right now a lot of teams are playing
those two safeties
and the rams kind of lead the charge in
that that's fine
that's great you got to know how teams
are going to attack you though you got
to know you got to know that teams are
going to be willing and able to run the
football against you and if you're going
to do that i think their corners and
their safeties got to be way more
aggressive when they're in run support
because san francisco just ran the ball
and the corners and safeties are hanging
back like what's up you got to know that
teams are going to do that so i think
those are two things they got to fix
feels like uh most of these quarterbacks
get one week i mentioned jameis winston
week one always a dark horse for the mvp
josh allen had a week tom brady's had
one dak prescott lamar jackson's had one
and now it's mac jones week
did the analyst what did they get wrong
or did they get wrong with with mack
jones or did he just end up with the
right place the right team the right
coach
i think a lot of people had it wrong you
know um so
i i call college football games and i
remember doing the alabama arkansas game
and sitting down with the people around
alabama and asking them about mac jones
and i'll never forget steve sarkesian
the head coach of texas who was their oc
um talking to me about
how much
better mack was because he was the scout
team quarterback playing against the
alabama defense
and we were just having the conference i
played scout team quarterback a lot as a
backup and we were just having that
conversation
and it made me think you have you get so
much better because you have to play
so fast when you're playing scout team
against the starters you are forced to
play so fast and you learn because
there's no consequence to bad plays and
practice when you're that guy you learn
so much about what you can and cannot do
how you use these things your eyeballs
how you use your brain
and i think that was the thing that i
fell in love with with mac in the draft
process and i was the person who was
pounding the table he should go three to
san francisco and i had firmly believe
that kyle wanted mac at three i think
well we're an era where you know
physically we have fallen in love with
the the physical attributes of
quarterbacks as we should as we should
josh and lamar and and patrick
um but at the end of the day the
quarterback position has always been
can you think and can you throw and if
you do those two things at an incredibly
high level
consistently you are gonna be really
really really good and i think we became
so obsessed with well he's not fast that
a lot of people
lost sight of he plays really fast and
i think that's the thing you're seeing
is he just plays
so fast and he's got it if i redrafted
dan
yeah
the first quarterback off the board
trevor lawrence okay the second
quarterback off the board
yeah i think we're having a conversation
i really do i i think that now i i want
to be fair zach wilson you know we
understand the situation that he's been
in i think we're having a conversation
because everything that you need to be
good at quarterback matt does we haven't
seen that out of zac yet now mack has
also been supported to show that zach
has not
but i think we're having a conversation
um
zach can still do things that mac jones
just can't he just he physically has the
ability to do things that mac jones just
cannot
um
my wife oh she just came in yeah
does she love mac jones as well
no she don't like mac jones not she's a
philly girl man she uh she's she's gonna
ride with jalen hurts until the eagles
decide to move on from jaylen are you
all in on jalen hurts
no no no i'm not all in okay i'm not all
in i i still think that you know i'll
still remain adam and i i think
philadelphia made a mistake in regards
to that um in regards to
you know the cards i will say this you
know i've been really impressed with
jalen i think if you know jalen hurts
can you become
a consistent
pocket passing quarterback and i think
week after week he's starting to show
that a little bit he really has i
thought there was a play in the denver
game this past week that kind of is the
imagery of hey yes i can and he's
starting to do it more and more
the browns are fading
i don't know if they've they've ever
been in the limelight this year dan i
don't know if they've ever you know had
the light to fade i think that
oh man expectations where where's the
defense you i can blame baker i can
blame no running backs offensive line
uh the defense seems to be getting away
with something here
yeah their defense mainly the back end
is just poor you know they they can't
cover and and i know they try they try
to play zone they're not good in zone i
think when they're in zone excuse me
when they're in zone i think they're way
too soft in their zone coverage
like you could play zone coverage and
still be
intentional still be physical allow
teams to feel your presence they just
give you completions when they play man
i still believe that they don't allow
their guys to play hands-on and man
coverage wait like denzel ward is a man
corner at his best and they don't allow
him to play this i think greg newsom is
a man corner at his best they don't have
you know every football
unit
needs to have something when that when
the
essay crap hits the fan the doodle hits
the fan like you got to have something
that you can turn to and say we're doing
this right now they don't have that and
i think their coverage because then they
got the best pass rush unit in the nfl
statistically yeah they're the best
password shooting in the nfl if you have
the best passwords unit nfl you should
be good in coverage and um that it's
really let them down i think their
communication still struggles when they
play man um so deep i think defensively
has been the absolute weakness weakest
part of their team i'll touch i'll say
this about the offense um
specifically of new england
i was really disappointed in kevin
stefanski baker didn't play good
they go on that first drive 11 plays
dearness johnson runs for 54 yards he's
got seven carries for 54 yards on that
first drive
they ran the ball three more times in
the first half that's like we could bill
was great the plan defensively was great
when you get a coach
to go away from
what their greatest attribute is you've
already won the game
you've already won and for them to i
don't care if i'm playing tailback the
strength of their offense are those five
boys up front i don't care who the
tailback is you got to run
be who you are at your absolute best
against new england
do you get out of household chores by
acting like you're on zoom calls all day
i actually love household chores i'm a
weirdo man like i'm a weirdo so um one
of the things i love to do is wash
dishes i don't use the dishwasher often
um because i like to dry dishes i also
like to make my kids dry the dishes
because i think it teaches them like hey
you got
it's not a chore dude this is something
you want to eat you got to drink wash
and dry your dishes wait is your wife
right there in the kitchen listening to
this you can vouch for me she give out
she is it's true yeah it's true okay um
i'm not a huge fan of the folding the
laundry but i will do it just to you
know we got we got six humans in our
house so i can't i can't go ahead you
know fold
the kids will try to fold laundry at
times so
okay
i gotta drop off lunch boxes at school
i gotta watch tape i gotta prepare for
cincinnati smu i gotta drop off lunch
boxes at school is cincinnati gonna make
the final four
i don't think so um
as much as my emotional heart wants them
to this is my second cincinnati game
i'll say this about cincinnati i think
their defense
gives them the ability to beat anyone in
america i think their defense is that
good
um i don't think over the past month
they've buried teams and that's on them
you know i think you've got to bury
teams if you're going to be that team
and
want to get in um i think michigan's
really good i called michigan penn state
last week i think michigan is really
good i think michigan state is a really
good football team um
who has a chance to be to ohio state
michigan or michigan state
i think michigan has a better chance to
beat ohio state i really i like their
coverage in michigan um aiden hutchinson
and david ojabo their two rush ends are
phenomenal players um i think they're
you know their consistency line up like
michigan will put
six seven offensive linemen on the field
with a tight end or two and just hey we
are unapologetic right now i think
that's the difference between the
michigan teams like the team this year
that i've called two michigan games and
the teams of the past is they are
playing in the style that jim wants them
to play and i think that's different uh
i think michigan's got a chance to beat
ohio state i do
uh safe travels always great to talk to
you and uh good luck today with your
chores thanks man go steph curry that's
uh that's dan orlovsky nfl live